so said with white Fiat II Prinsloo do
to give birth in just a few months Adam
Levine is ready for fatherhood
can you imagine Adam Levine being your
father he let me me I was on set with
Adam and rock legend Sammy Hagar who's
serving up advice as a team mentor on
the voice season 11 be the greatest your
life data baby oh hell yeah
but taking home another victory for Team
Adam that would be a pretty great day -
this season the maroon 5 frontman is up
against longtime friend of me Blake
Shelton and newcomers Miley Cyrus and
Alicia Keys how are the girls handling
the whole experience and how are they
handling your and Blake's bickering
stick they're good they're doing well
yes you know there's there's late if you
notice that the voice I'm hearing
Blake's here and that will never change
needs to be two people in between us
we're like the they were like the weird
bookends and and they're they're
handling it very well they're a little
disturbed sometimes a little shocked
speaking of shocked Adam dropped quite
the bombshell during our interview we're
the same kind of people he just he's
like my son we're here to announce that